Constraint propagation also connects to human cognition.
First, constraint propagation is a very general purpose method like,
means analysis. In both knowledge based AI and in human cognition,
constraint propagation allows us to use our knowledge of the world,
in order to make sense of it. Constraints can be of any kind. Symbolic,
as well as numeric. We discussed symbolic constraints in today's lesson.
A good example of numeric constraints comes from XL spreadsheets,
with which most of you are familiar. If the columns in a particular
spreadsheet are connected to some formula, and you make a change in one column,
then the change is propagated into all the columns of the spreadsheet.
That's an example of Numerical Constraint Propagation.
We have seen constraint propagation under other topics as well.
For example, planning, and understanding, and scripts. The next topic,
configuration, will build on this notion of constraint propagation.